problema 47 que gráfica representa el
sistema de ecuaciones que se muestra a
continuación y nos da dos ecuaciones y
cada una de éstas representa una recta
están en la forma que es igual a mx más
b mx más b donde m es la pendiente de la
recta y b es la intersección con el eje
y entonces aquí nos están diciendo que
ambas tienen intersección con el eje y a
la altura 3 la primera tiene pendiente
negativa de hecho igual a menos 1 y la
segunda tiene pendiente positiva igual a
1 a ver si con esta información podemos
determinar cuál gráfica representa este
sistema veamos en la opción a tenemos
que las rectas cortan al eje y en el
punto menos 3 y eso no es lo que
queremos esto no es lo que queremos
queremos que intersectan aquí arriba
porque b es igual a 3 entonces ésta no
sería bueno es una lástima porque parece
que si tienen las pendientes que
necesitamos
y -1 bueno ni modo vamos al ac enlace
tenemos dos rectas paralelas entonces
pues no puede ser verdad porque deberían
tener la misma pendiente pero una debe
ser uno y la otra menos uno y además
tampoco concuerda la intersección con el
eje y aquí es tres aquí es menos tres
entonces ésta tampoco sería vamos a ver
la opción b
ah mira esto se ve prometedor las dos
rectas pasan por el eje x a la altura 3
es una de las cosas que necesitábamos y
necesitábamos que una tuviera pendiente
1 que parece ser ésta y la otra menos 1
vamos a ver si sí y aquí avanzamos 1 a
la derecha subimos 1 entonces ésta tiene
ecuación e igual a x + 3 y esta de acá
si avanzamos 1 y avanzamos 1 baja 1
entonces sus pendientes menos 1 y por lo
tanto esta recta de abajo tiene ecuación
igual a menos menos x 3 eso es lo que
queríamos si x 3 y menos x 3
entonces la respuesta sería b y nada más
para no dejar abandonada la t pues no
tenemos que aquí cruz entre sí aquí en
menos 3 entonces ésta no puede ser vamos
a los siguientes problemas siguiente
página
el problema de 48 george ya tiene
exactamente un peso un peso en monedas
de 10 y 5 centavos ok si yo ya tiene el
doble de monedas de 10 centavos que de 5
centavos cuántas monedas de 5 centavos
tiene joshua bueno digamos que la
cantidad de monedas de 10 centavos es de
d mayúscula y la cantidad de monedas de
5 centavos es se va y nos están diciendo
que yo ya tiene el doble de monedas de
10 centavos que de 5 centavos entonces
de la cantidad de monedas de 10 centavos
es igual a 2 veces la cantidad de
monedas de 5 centavos y nos preguntan
cuántas monedas de 5 centavos tiene
joshua la otra información que tenemos
es que en total tiene un peso como
podemos escribir eso pues sabes un peso
un peso o déjame ponerlo así 10 0.1 lo
voy a poner así 0.10 sea 10 centavos que
colabora cada moneda de 10 centavos
0.05
que colabora cada moneda de cinco
centavos es igual a un peso a lo mejor
convenga a poner esta ecuación en
centavos está en pesos sí o sea esta es
la cantidad de dinero que tiene por las
monedas de 10 centavos está por la de 5
y este es el peso que tiene pero si
pasamos todo a centavos creo que se ve
un poco más amigable nos quedaría 10 x
de cada moneda de 10 centavos pues da 10
centavos más 5% cada moneda de cinco
centavos 25 centavos es igual a 100
porque un peso son 100 centavos en
realidad esta ecuación es la misma que
la de arriba simplemente multiplicando
por ciento multiplicando por 100
sale bueno con esta ecuación de aquí
abajo y la información que nos dicen
aquí podemos encontrar el valor de cee
déjame sustituir de aquí abajo y tenemos
este valor de de lo voy a poner aquí
abajo déjame escribir de este lado
tenemos 10 de
+ ce es igual a 100 entonces 10 por dos
veces se hace es igual a 100 aquí no
falta un 5 verdad un 5 qué bueno que me
di cuenta un 5 10 por 2 es 20 entonces
20 c + 5 c es igual a 100 100 25 son 25
25 c es igual a 100 c es igual a 100 100
entre 25 entre 25 entonces se es igual a
4 la cantidad de monedas de 5 centavos
que tiene yo ya son 4 la respuesta sería
ah y si quisiéramos pues podemos
encontrar la cantidad de monedas de 10
centavos sería el doble serían 8
entonces esas ocho monedas colaboran con
80 centavos y luego 4 monedas de 5 son
otros 20 y con eso se completa el peso
entonces todo está muy bien vamos ahora
el problema 49
en el problema en el problema 49
pregunta cuáles son todos los posibles
valores de x de modo que 10 veces el
valor absoluto de x sea igual a 2.5
bueno déjame primero pasar este 10
dividiendo es decir dividir entre 10 de
ambos lados nos daría que el valor
absoluto de x porque aquí se cancela es
igual a 2.5 entre 10 2.50 y 10 pues b
2.5 por 2 de 5 y por otros 2 es 10
entonces esto es un cuarto un cuarto a
lo mejor es un poco truculento verlo así
también se puede hacer la división de
casita si hacemos 2.5 entre 10 entre 10
a ver déjame poner algunos 000
10 cabe dos veces en 25 aquí le pondría
22 x 10 6 20
25 20 es 5 baja este 0 luego aquí cabe 5
veces 5 por 10 50 y aquí sí lo restó me
queda 0 y el punto decimal va aquí
entonces también podemos pensarlo como
0.25 de esta forma el valor absoluto de
x es igual a 0.25
de modo que uno de los posibles valores
de x 0.25 verdad si x es 0.25 entonces
su valor absoluto de 0.25
pero tenemos tenemos otro chance puede
ser que x sea negativo y entonces en
este caso x sería igual a menos menos
0.25 y funciona porque al sacar el valor
absoluto nos queda que se quita este
signo y entonces también es solución de
modo que la respuesta sería ah y ahora
que lo pienso esta división de acá pues
fue un poco la tossa a lo mejor
simplemente debía haber recorrido el
punto decimal verdad cuando dividimos un
número entre 10 y otra vez 2.5 entre 10
simplemente recorremos el punto decimal
un lugar hacia la izquierda y otra vez
tenemos 0.25 bueno ni modo
llegaste un poquito de tiempo pero ya
vimos varias formas de hacerlo problemas
el problema 50 nos preguntan cuál de las
siguientes opciones es equivalente a 12
x mayor que 3 x x 2 bueno vamos a
resolver esta desigualdad 12 x mayor que
3 x x 2 aquí hay que distribuir el 312 x
mayor que 3 x 3 por 12 6 menos 6
como 6 ahora lo que voy a hacer es
restar 6 de ambos lados
no voy a hacer déjame ver qué hacer voy
a restar uno de ambos lados puesto uno
puesto uno voy a pasar las equis a la
izquierda este se cancela con este este
con este se hace menos 7 me queda que
menos 12 x es mayor que 3 x 7 y ahora
voy a restar 3 x de ambos lados déjame
con tomar un color diferente menos 3x
acá menos 3 x acá menos 3 x 2 x es menos
5 x queda menos 5 x mayor que menos 7
porque de este lado se cancelan y aquí
aquí va una parte truculenta tenemos que
dividir entre menos 5 de ambos lados
pero hay que tener cuidado porque al
dividir entre un número negativo este
signo de acá cambia vale entonces aquí
voy a dividir entre menos 5 acá también
entre menos 5 pero este signo debe de
cambiar este se cancela con este y nos
queda que x aquí era mayor entonces se
hace menor que menos 7 entre menos 5
entonces ésta de aquí sería la respuesta
pero no querían que hiciéramos eso
simplemente querían que encontráramos un
una de estas que fuera equivalente a lo
mejor es uno de los pasos que tenemos la
puesta está de acá la opción c la opción
c es equivalente al primer paso que
hicimos a este de acá vale entonces la
respuesta sería c bueno no le hace ya
practicamos un poco cómo resolver
desigualdades y no nos tomó tanto tiempo
verdad pero a lo mejor una buena
elección es eso de de revisar las
opciones antes de empezar a intentar el
problema bueno vamos al problema 51 en
el problema 51 nos preguntan qué
ecuación representa la línea recta de la
siguiente gráfica en la siguiente
gráfica y esta de acá
a veces eso se puede hacer a simple
vista pensamos a esta recta como una
recta de la forma igual a m y x + b
dónde m es la pendiente y b es la
intersección con el eje y vamos a ver si
se puede a simple vista ver la
intersección con el eje y es
aproximadamente 1.5 chin bueno no
podemos estar tan seguros de que sea 1.5
pero b lo que sí podemos ver es que pasa
por el punto 11 este punto de acá y pasa
por el punto 30 este punto de acá
entonces con eso podemos calcular la
pendiente verdad porque tenemos que
avanzamos 2 bueno estando aquí avanzamos
2 y bajamos 1 entonces entonces déjame
ponerlo m vamos a empezar con la
pendiente es igual al cambio en dividido
entre el cambio en x el cambio en ya fue
uno bueno fue menos 1 verdad esto es
igual a menos 1 y tenemos que dividir
entre el cambio en x que fue 2
entonces la pendiente es igual a menos
un medio y si es igual a menos un medio
cuando vamos uno hacia la izquierda
entonces vamos a subir una verdad si la
pendiente es negativa y vamos hacia
atrás subimos entonces si pasa por aquí
por el 1.5 eso está muy bien entonces ya
tenemos la ecuación de la recta tenemos
que la pendiente es menos un medio sería
ye yé es igual a menos un medio de equis
y pasa por 1.5 más 1.5 pasa en el eje
por 1.5 bueno vamos a ver si está aquí
en las opciones no esto no está es que
lo pusieron de otra forma con ji x del
lado izquierdo bueno vamos a simplificar
es un poquito voy a multiplicar por dos
de ambos lados y aquí me quedaría 22 es
igual a 2 x menos un medio es 1 es menos
1 entonces sería menos x
2 por un 1.52 por 1.5 estrés ok y ahora
hay que pasar la equis del lado
izquierdo sumamos x de ambos lados más x
mas x entonces aquí se cancela y nos
quedaría la ecuación que nos queda es x
+ 2 que es igual a 3 y es así esta si es
la opción a la respuesta sería a muy
bien